disons que Miss France ça doit être le
reflet d'une de la jeune fille française
scène de corps et d'esprit
ils ont tous les ans on élimise France
une très jolie fiche choisie parmi des
centaines d'autres très jolies filles
c'est une beauté dont on a longtemps
publié les mensurations accompagné du
terme les canons de la beauté c'est à
dire les proportions du corps acceptées
comme l'expression de la beauté madame
de Fontenay comment choisit-on la plus
jolie fille de France
finalement c'est assez simple ce sont
les spectateurs qui les lisent dans la
mesure où d'abord les jeunes filles qui
participent avec son Miss France sont
des candidates qui ont été au préalable
élus dans toutes les provinces de notre
pays et c'est la représente maintenant
50 candidates donc on commence par avoir
des beaux T qui représentent le type
d'une province exactement et ça c'est
très très net parce qu'il est certain
que les jeunes filles du Nord ou de
l'Est sont tout à fait différents de
celle du Midi ou de ou d'autres régions
de France
quels sont les critères de choix à
partir des provinces et jusqu'à Miss
France finalement c'est une sorte de
d'harmonie générale bien sûr des
proportions harmonieuses du corps mais
également un visage expressif et
certains que c'est très difficile de
dire qu'il y a des normes ça ne se
définit pas vraiment la beauté
tout de même peut-être que depuis le
début où on a élu la première Miss
France les critères ont changé oui non
parce que finalement quand on pense à
Yvette Labrousse qui a été Miss France
en 1930 qui maintenant l'avez-vous à 3
et bien elle est une très grande femme
il est certain que il y a de nombreuses
années les femmes étaient plus petites
que maintenant les jeunes maintenant ont
tendance à grandir à sa mincir mais
finalement il va être labo c'était une
type de femme qui pourrait peut-être
encore maintenant être Miss France Miss
France cette année
c'est une ravissante marseillaise Sylvie
Parreira une blonde qui succède à une
brune puisque l'année dernière c'était
une réunionnaise donc elle est aussi
blonde que la présidente était brune
est-ce qu'il y a des conditions minimum
pour être élu il faut avoir 17 ans dans
l'année qui suit l'élection parce que
pour participer au concours chez nous il
faut avoir impérativement 17 ans il
n'est pas rare de voir des jeunes filles
qui ont à peine 15 ans qui se présentent
et qui et qui ont déjà un développement
physique tout à fait de femmes presque
en fait elles ont l'air déjà de femmes
mais qu'elle soit blonde brune
alors là pas du tout pas des colorés
nous nous essayons justement de de
supprimer tout ce qui est artifice nous
interdisons les fossiles les perruques
les fausses naturellement maintenant les
maillots sont des maillots de de nageuse
des maillots 10 compétitions donc de ce
côté-là on ne peut pas tricher mais
c'est il faut disons que Miss France
elle doit être le reflet d'une de la
jeune fille française
scène de corps et d'esprit
[Musique]